ce qu'en pensent les professionnels en
france pour en parler nous sommes avec
arthur reversât dirigeant du groupe
familial hôtellerie et restaurants la
folie douce
bonsoir arthur reversade merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés philippe pweto ce
directeur de l'office de tourisme les
carros d'arâches domaine skiable grand
massif en haute-savoie bonjour à vous
aussi merci d'être avec nous alors bon
arthur reversade s'est ouvert mais pas
les remontées alors quand on connaît
votre magnifique restaurant au beau
milieu des pistes on se dit ça va être
un petit peu compliqué de grimper avec
les skis sur les épaules quelle est
votre réaction en tout cas cette annonce
du premier ministre ce matin
effectivement depuis l occupation de
monsieur le président on a anticipé
jeudi rennes fermeture nos
établissements jusque sûrement le 10 ou
le vin le 20 janvier au delà d'être une
crise économique c'est je dirais surtout
une crise sociale qui se se profile chez
nous la folie douce ses huit
établissements répartis à travers le de
l'arc alpin français et c'est surtout
700 collaborateurs 700 collaborateurs
que malheureusement cette année nous ne
sommes pas en mesure d'embaucher tout de
suite ce sont donc sept cents familles
qui se retrouvent à la rue et on ne sait
pas vraiment que faire alors philippe
preto c'est vrai qu'on se dit toujours à
céder les français plutôt aisés qui vont
se retrouver sur les pistes de ski
merde sur reversade vient de nous le
rappeler il s'agit aussi et surtout de
beaucoup d'emplois en l'occurrence 700
familles nous disent et ils vous
partagez cette
inquiétude aussi de votre côté si on
parle des emplois saisonniers tout à
fait puisque au niveau de la station de
ski on a fait un sondage auprès des
socioprofessionnels de notre station est
globalement donc pas mal de temps pas ne
seront pas renouveler cet hiver donc
près de 35 à 40% ce qui est quand même
énorme et le chiffre d'affaires des
remontées mécaniques cette période la
salle autour de 2 millions d'euros
les stations de charme on sait qu'il ya
peu près pour un euro des remontées
mécaniques il ya 6 euros qui sont
dépensés dans la station donc ça fait un
manque à gagner aux alentours remontées
mécaniques plus on va dire le tissu
économique de près de 14 millions
d'euros et c'est considérable alors
arthur versa de vous parler
effectivement des conséquences
importantes économique mais sur cette
décision du premier ministre avant
d'ailleurs de vous faire réagir je
voudrais qu'on écoute laurent reynaud
délégué général du domaine skiable de
france les gens auraient donc le droit
de se rendre en station mais pas celui
de pratiquer le ski le ski une activité
de plein air que le gouvernement veut
interdire pour décourager les français
de se rendre à la montagne alors que
toutes les autres activités et serait
autorisée alors on vous imagine un petit
peu dans dans les tuyaux il ya dû avoir
une forme de lobby pour essayer que ces
stations au ruf pour les fêtes
est ce que vous comprenez tout de même
cette décision du premier ministre
je pense que si on est d'une certaine
manière des des professionnels de la
restauration de l'hôtellerie de l'intel
montée du tourisme d'une manière
générale mais nous ne sommes pas des
professionnels du coc vide je ne suis
pas un expert scientifique et donc sur
cette partie là effectivement je m'en
remets à l'état et on suit sagement leur
décision voilà ce qu'il en est par
contre effectivement je rebondis sur sur
ce sujet une station de ski sens qui ne
peut pas vivre c'est à dire que les
stations de ski
ce ne sont pas seulement le sport
d'hiver mais c'est une destination
vacances à la montagne et le ce qu'il
fait partie d'un maillon de la chaîne
la restauration les différents services
les différentes attractivité qu'il a
dans une station on travaille tous
ensemble main dans la main et si un
maillon manquant malheureusement
l'expérience du client
on va en pâtir philippe pweto vous vous
trouvez ça injuste alors c'est vrai
qu'on vous parlait 10 gallons se
souvient que c'était un véritable
cluster au début de l'épidémie mais dans
les bars de la station et pas
nécessairement sur les pistes elle
manque de cohérence cette décision
gouvernementale selon vous c'est vrai
que tout le tout le monde du dessin sion
2 qui était très très surpris étonné on
avait des stades et assurance mais on
savait qu'il y aurait des décisions qui
seraient peut-être positif si on nous
laissait dix jours de plus
du coup tout s'est accéléré entre le
mardi et le mercredi et ce qui fait que
du coup maintenant sans les remontées
mécaniques c'est vrai que ça devient
plus compliqué on a du mal à comprendre
comment on pourra peut-être aller faire
ce qu'ils rendront peut-être aller faire
de la raquette ou du ski de fond et ne
pas prendre les remontées mécaniques
maintenant faut prendre ce qui reste et
de positif et dire ben voilà les
remontées mécaniques sont fermés mais
les villages et des stations vont être
accessible qu'il y aura des activités
que vous allez pouvoir prendre l'air
oxygène vous oxygéner vous ressourcer
voilà vous vous évader dans cette belle
nature montagnarde pour évacuer un petit
peu tout le stress du quotidien
ça va faire du bien à tout le monde il y
aura des restaurants il y aura des
commerces sur deux volets de la vente à
emporter au niveau des restaurants on le
sait mais je pense que les stations de
ski ont un rôle à jouer et si par
ailleurs ça peut protéger on va dire au
niveau des rétais conditions sanitaires
une ouverture au mois de janvier pour
faire une saison on va dire correct
janvier les vacances de février et
pouvoir traverser le mois de mars
peut-être qu'on dira que cette décision
n'était pas si mauvaise que ça alors on
va essayer de rester positif de dire
venez nous voir on est on a envie de
vous recevoir nos commerces seront là et
est positive on élit l'on nous peut-être
que nos élus ont pris peut-être des
bonnes décisions pour protéger le ski de
de demain ou après-demain du 20 janvier
jusqu'au 30 mars au 15 avril
c'est tout ce qu'on vous souhaite un
parce que évidemment l'essentiel de la
saison
elle se fait surtout pendant les
vacances de février
il n'empêche arthur reversade vous ne
craignez pas cette concurrence déloyale
à laquelle faisait allusion d'ailleurs
angela merkel qui elle plaide carrément
pour une interdiction des vacances de
ski jusqu'au 10 janvier dans toute
l'europe
parce qu'on sait que l'autriche aimerait
bien sauver sa petite saison noël la
suisse qui ne fait pas partie de
l'europe elle devrait tout simplement
rouvrir c'est compliqué pour à gérer
pour vous cela s'est effectivement
extrêmement complexe un fils dans un
monde global et nos stades chanteuse qui
sont des stations qui accueille en
moyenne 80% d'étrangers je me vois mal
faire et saison de ski sans notre
clientèle étrangère
et oui effectivement oui nous avons peur
d'un avec fruits de clients qui
partirait sur des stations autrichiennes
notamment ou suisse c'est compliqué à
moyen terme de retourner capter cette
clientèle pour la ram sur la destination
france
effectivement compliqué cette
concurrence de 12 tout à fait c'est vrai
que nous on est très proche de la suisse
des collègues directeurs de stations
suisses qui ont déjà ouvert comme
verbier qui vont ouvrir pour d'autres
avec les récents d'attitude certainement
également
c'est vrai que on a une certaine
appréhension maintenant faut rester
proactif
il faut se dire que c'est à nous de les
séduire de s'adapter de faire une bonne
communication pour les prochaines
vacances et d'essayer de faire que ces
clientèles ne ne tarde pas sur les pays
étrangers je le crains plus sur les
clientèles étrangères je le crains moins
sur les clientèles françaises
ces destinations autrichiennes et
suisses
voilà maintenant il faut regarder ce qui
va se passer espérons qu'il y aura une
entente européenne pour que tout le
monde le soit logé à la même enseigne
c'est ce qu'on espère et on l'avenir
nous le dira en tout cas dans l'est dans
les prochaines semaines certainement
merci arthur reversât merci également
philippe